if you disagree you're more than welcome
to sit down and change my mind
louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Music]
it June which marks louder with louder
third annual cultural appropriation
month where we take you across the globe
to appreciate and appropriate all the
great cultures it has to offer
this week the final weeks of this June
we take you to the culture of Honduras
welcome to the cultural appropriation
about this week number four to
appropriators to appreciate we have some
Honduras facts here I hope you guys can
can you hear me there can you hear me
gerald
I think I can hear you Steven okay yes
it's been in a Gerald hey Blythe yet
before we start watching you do too
kind of hard for me do the question of
the day given given the questions got a
question of the day is violence ever the
answer yes so I do believe a what do you
what do you think there's time
[Music]
it's June which marks louder would crowd
the third annual cultural appropriation
month where we take you across the globe
to appreciate and appropriate all the
great culture it has to offer this week
the final week of this June we take you
to the culture of Honduras with you I'm
seeing double ah let's do a great guest
today we have dr. Jordan Peterson on the
show he's going to be on in the coming
weeks for a long-form interview for a
new thing we're gonna be doing something
a little bit unique and we have Nick
DiPaolo on the show got punched in the
face by a lady with Birkenstocks that
hurts and questions day before we move
on is you know the discrepancy between
Donald Trump president Trump the
coverage in the polls it's so wide we'll
talk about that a little bit how do you
think history will remember him as the
man the media painted him to be or as an
effective president of course I hid the
notification del if you're watching on
youtube or join my club or bookmark the
page because notifications might not
work producing with me in video duty as
always as year two is not gay follow me
on Twitter and not get you and me as
crowded with your comments your thoughts
your photo shops your costumes I don't
know the hundred us today
fun fact highest murder rate in the
world I was gonna say industrialized
know what are you check under your seat
no okay I'll be signing those later
meeting great by the way
Aronson fine too still a Pataki
monetized and aji Morgan Jr what's one
of the day one of the day is Sparkman
wilderness wilderness I liked you better
in an urn in don't even stop the
computers in Honduras BP but computers
never met Metis life's matter on Twitter
that he mumbles he does he tries and
German or the other German interns who
want his job from Merkel ah that's all I
have for fun facts 400 upon fun text
there are there's no one murder rate
there are no in fact there is not fun at
all candy it's just like nice fun
computer nice
I love how his bullet is dead center
yeah name it was an execution was
it was an excuse the Germans though yes
I'm great first so we do have a lot of
news to get to and this has been a very
very busy week but first a pornography
website has now added closed captioning
for viewers with hearing loss this comes
from Engadget feature will help viewers
distinguish which person is speaking at
any one time because that's important
motion in addition non dialogue sounds
that are relevant to the storyline our
scene will be highlighted so they
cracked the code for the deaf still no
luck with one handed Braille that's
still a struggle out there I'm not gonna
beautiful mine now a spell just lots of
bowels that's that's the point how do
you spell captions yeah the thought I
didn't go to college
look this is a terrible summer reading
program okay yes was a bad way to get
people to read it's it's it's also but
it is actually a huge part of the new
Big Brother program oh yeah it's all
just a van
a San Francisco man by the way who knew
who was scared scared for his life when
he reported that unprompted and this is
the kind of thing gives me shivers mmm
true story true story right Sven yes
alright the true story I'm fine his
Alexa spoke out quote every time I close
my eyes all I see is people dying and
this comes as no surprise to us here at
lotta was crowded with her experience
with Alexa we didn't think it comes this
soon and so it begins
to even forever yes come with me if you
want to live but it is multi there
Wolfie
[Music]
close one beer rationing is actually
starting it's unrolling in Europe to a
carbon dioxide crisis NBC at least five
gas producers in northern Europe began a
plan shut down during the early summer
months to resolve maintenance issues it
deals with co2 that what is what is
Northern Europe exactly spent that way I
guess every come to that's north north
of Italy what it will be BB Germany
there will be Iowa and not Italy so the
non-greasy wants you know basically
countries that has some somewhat
financially stable yeah so they're going
for co2 this is what they're doing now
the government rationing of beer come
and take it but you really come and take
it that they can't do anything we have
no second amendment a prepper in Europe
oh yeah homeless person you not purchase
a gun to protect it if you did you
couldn't talk about it yeah distinguish
them from the hobos the grocery carts
the Scots it's got to be I can't shoot
myself I can't stab myself I can't drink
myself to death know if these little
mission cars I can't even suck on the
exhaust that just gives me okay I can't
really kill myself on the Tesla I can't
even afford both rivers not gonna be
named get let me suck on his exhaust
he's got a schedule to keep
I don't want to kill myself without pain
[Laughter]
always runnin late it's socialism
that's all quit like you live it to my
wife she shows up truancy officer with a
stick it's gotta be miserable there I'm
so glad that you get out of there
hundred years ago we repaid what we left
we've yeah we saw this coming in fact
wasn't about tea it was about beer but
from this America actually to say that
with
found sobriety Europeans woke up across
the entire continent saying wow soccer
does suck so the one guy who shows that
what the flask issue as you spit it all
of a cookie dough here's one thing we
notice when I went to Austin better we
went to Austin and we saw these puppies
billboards roll out have you seen these
you know you that's right you didn't go
there son computer it's it's a billboard
for it for HIV pills they've been
popping up across the country there's
one F without fear that's it where's
that billboard if they're not get your I
think it's in that LA that particularly
in Lawson of course it is they're not
even hiding it do you realize that if we
were to do a joke a sketch F without
fear for HIV we got more flak for a much
more tame wishbone parody history of the
AIDS HIV story exactly so we look at a
peppery so the billboards a big part of
this in Washington DC it's their plan to
get the HIV rate down they want to get
more uninfected people on prep PR EP
it's a to medicine combination pill that
apparently that prevents HIV I think
it's just a pill that you put in your
your pee hole it doesn't let the avian
it's really more of a making it I don't
know why they call it a pill why are we
spending money on that I don't know how
many years later we snow better we're
still funding those dams here's a real
estate I understand drugs after you have
it yes sure I don't think it should get
as much funding as cancer or diabetes or
diabetes or all corners like it but
we're spending money on awareness
billboards to prevent it just don't have
unprotected anal sex with random dudes
in a truck stop that's it that's
entirely preventable argument do you
guys it I always said what bothers me
most about this people get so mad
because it's politically incorrect how
often you hear when people talk about
sharks like oh you know
he's struck by lightning then suffer
stuff the spiders more afraid of you
then why are we using argument you're
more likely to be struck by lightning
attacked by a shark on land then get
hiv/aids if you're not having
unprotected sodomy in truck stops with
strangers or using intravenous drugs
without cleaning needles your chance
like it's simple what else can you do
the truck stop though wait a second you
you go to the truck stop and you just
get gas flapjacks but okay but where are
you but where do you get your heroin I
don't so you bring your heroin with you
to the truck stop and your pool Lou and
have sex with him afterward no what are
you a monk they assume the rest of the
world is just like them it's I mean it's
just it just just that's that's none of
your van HIV we don't need a billboard
we don't need a pill sorry we're the
jerks for bringing it up by the way it
says F without fear
I don't like they can say that but we
can't say it's preventable
yesterday's medical terminology is
today's hate speech and today's hate
speech is tomorrow's colloquialism when
they admit it dull is a British knife
[Laughter]
the problem yourself speaking of places
that are silly one of Canada's biggest
music festivals now is on pause because
of a protected bird it's known as the
kill dear lovely name and a burp of the
nest of four eggs that cannot be removed
without federal permission come from CNN
it says I have to say this is one of the
most challenging problems we've ever
been presented with recently the
executive director of Bluesfest told
reporters but the festival organisers
it's it's it seems silly but they're
actually really hopeful of their chances
because when you can fix the situation
everyone is everyone is happy that's
that's ideal and tell them was that they
enlisted the help of I think we have him
here to talk about the Canadian fiasco
Dennis Rodman Dennis Rodman thank you
for being there sir I'm just so happy
okay that's great but how are you
solving the problem I got so many death
threats I love this bird I'm believing
this bird right here I believe it is
been loyal he took everything I took
everybody think they could throw at me
and I'm still standing right here with
this bird
yeah no I'm not sure that's bird is oh
this bar can't even go old like me he
didn't need to go home he already home
is in Britain in Canada you know a fetus
clump of cells yeah Burt a stop stop the
festival yeah you say bird eggs Oh bird
egg you said bird day when these guys
said it's the biggest problem they've
ever been faced with a pretty sheltered
lives
[Laughter]
that's what's the realm of pain in
history well let me think uh we didn't
fight off the royalty we know but we
just we did our potato boys we had our
potato we said okay to the royalty we
kissed the ring we still have them on
felt the queen and her money one time
weren't really a country it burned down
the White House you guys were pretty mad
about that and then we had a real
problem with some bird eggs yeah yeah
that was a big one by the way thanks for
providing all the National Defense
America hey one thing actually before I
move on I was talking with this know
maybe someone out there can help me no
doctors I've been able to describe this
to me I have one extra muscle on my left
side here yeah I don't have on my right
tell you a bit of a free that's a hole
no one likes a bragger extra it's
totally non-functional and I went into
specialists or they were like I don't
know have you done anything useful with
it Jimmy I do just concern that is when
you go to a doctor you'll get something
wrong here's just a gross lie and I'm
not sure that they do a screening
actually I was told till I was age 12 by
old white people at church that black
people were faster because they had
extra muscle in their leg oh yeah I
heard that one I had a teacher tell me
yeah that's not true I had a teacher in
high school tell me that he said till 12
it was at least 21 farts not believing
she wasn't a teacher my father's teacher
in Detroit taught him and this was
taught in schools that black people had
larger posteriors to retain water and
region this was no this was this was
Darwinism yeah we're gonna see they have
those small muscles in the leg so they
can walk easier to Europe all right so
listen we talking more about
polarization kind of who bears the brunt
for most of it with with dr. Peterson
next I think I think a big part of this
we've talked about I do you think it's
exclusive to the left III just says I'm
not gonna do the cop out I don't think
everyone is copping out when they do it
I think some people are but I know it
would be disingenuous of me to say it's
balance if there's not a give-and-take I
think it exists exclusively on the left
and we deal with it all the time I think
a big part of this so before we get to
that is the polarization that people
complain about which in and of itself is
not necessarily a bad thing is how out
of touch the left is and we've seen it
this week more than ever I think
whatever in my lifetime I would say
would you say that probably something
you're what you say in your left
absolutely pretty insane right now
Jarrod would you say 7% yeah I would say
kind of we talked with under Obama race
relations where the worst had ever been
in our lifetime with black lives matters
now it's all the relations well I think
there's an out of touch and is from the
left and the rest of America that has
never occurred
I want your Freeway if you if you if you
actually understand what I'm talking
about if you sense it out there's
palpable what am i talking about how out
of touch are they with the rest of
America up this is the world they live
in a sampling I even thought hey maybe
we'll talk about Donald Trump much
tonight and then he opened his mouth and
all manner of stupid came out and I'm
not joking when I say I would feel more
comfortable if Cersei Lannister was
running this country at this way what
would you say to him no I
what Sato might say you you're probably
the worst president than any country's
ever had I know this news is very
painful for a lot of people it feels
like for the next 30 years America is
gonna change in a horrible direction in
some ways it feels like all hope is dead
nothing can bring it back in 2017 when
we had the worst president in the
history of the United States
administration officials have been
sending babies and other young children
0:03 tender-age shelters in South Texas
lawyers and medical providers
I'm gonna have to hand this off okay
they just assume people are on board
remember Oprah was talking to we
couldn't find the video clip Oprah was
terrible I know things are bad out there
right now here's those things really are
unemployment the lowest in almost 20
years job participation rate is
extraordinarily I people have more money
in their paychecks than our lifetime
that's bad actually
this creates polarization we have people
going all right here's the worst
president ever and even when they're not
being aggressive you have a lot of
Americans there they're coming home from
payday and they're Washington opening
their check with their letter over
Washington me Kimball going that's my
money that's what hopeless this feels
like Stephen that's what you more money
exactly it's crazy to me as he claimed
are living under fascism look the
supreme court was a big thing yeah
what here's what's so good about this
yesterday but I didn't think I put fine
enough a point on it quite literally all
of the major decisions that people are
pissed about ruled in favor of freedom
and choice freedom to choose to join a
union freedom to choose this doesn't
destroy unions and it doesn't destroy
Pro abortion clinics it's like hey I
don't want to have to pay a union that's
fine I don't want to join a union that's
they're mad at the yes parents I don't
want to have to promote abortion
services you can do that I want to
create an abortion clinic how this is
fascism there's no I don't understand
this you know what I think you know what
I hope dies in this country what he's
talking about is dead and pardon my
language your ideology that's what's
dead up in the s bomb where we sitting
there's fun well the thing is that the
rulings were in favor of string true
through Constitution BP and so they they
just want activists on those courts and
actually there's a slate piece that just
came out today because I joked about
yesterday sure enough they had a piece
about right now they're proposing you
know next time the Democrat is in power
maybe we could just expand the Supreme
Court you know just yeah this is great
like that is a would be crazy abuse of
the legislative process it'll be crazy
abuse of I mean most insane no wit how
many of course you're changing did you
branch of government but I would imagine
you'd have to use all three branches and
one big giant cluster screw to make it
happen I don't even know if there's a
schoolhouse rock for this there's not
there's no file but we were joking about
that yesterday and they're saying let's
fundamentally let's create remember up
when gridlock was a bad thing by the way
floor did a gridlock in Washington know
Barack Obama had the house had this said
he had that when he study at everything
in wanted he couldn't get it done why
because of his crazy policies also
gridlock is beautiful yes that's what's
but now that when a creek gridlock in
the court what we need the grip gridlock
was terrible but now the ends justify
the means well what's the ends to make
sure that you have to join a union and
promote abortion
this can't be Nazi Germany you're coming
for the gays what's next none taxpayer
subsidized HIV prevention pills what do
I have to have stop having anal sex and
truck stops with strangers I'm not an
animal
god forbid yeah not on the Iowa not on
my watch Pol Pot and what happened cups
full ratings aren't 47% on par with
Barack Obama's at this point in his
brother pretty good despite unlike Obama
you're wondering his own water on this
one which I think that's to me that's
one great wonderful wonderful thing
about the Trump residency is that it is
just diminish the power of the media
they realize they just can't they don't
have an influence member remember that
one clip we played a long time ago Larry
King talked about the media's role I
think is lurking I don't think they can
influence elections yeah they don't like
presents anymore that's why they're
getting so pissed off is because they're
realizing it they have less influence
now than they have ever had all hope is
lost I mean in this and you pull I was
about to try it but I realize I can't do
Trevor Noah's acts because it's not like
a really South African accent this new
poll that we just had with the approval
rating at 47% there's just an array of
things that just pretty much affirms
that the left-wing part of their own
party product which is which is that in
that body it's so far away from the
general population that they do agree on
so much with Trump in you
there you go all right no I if you look
at it actually the source are you
talking about them it took a little
while to get to your beep-beep your
process well your scream about mass
hysteria with the immigration rate
separation of families and what they
what they do is they cite polls where
yes most Americans are against
separating families we are yeah everyone
in this room is but shockingly the
plural
Americans believe in enforcing the
borders right that's wrong for us the
meeting just spent an entire news cycle
hysterically bashing president Trump on
immigration and what happened they said
this shocked me this shocks you his
approval among Hispanics he's up ten
points in a month they love it they love
him I don't think that's ever happened
even with a Democrat Friday because so
many we're going to up to people going
deport the hater but the illegals make
me look bad I mean this is Aman he's
Betty voters babies of course exactly
yeah you're polling actual voters legal
Hispanics the highest Republican voting
bloc in the country Cuban Americans yeah
it's like 80 it's not even close
yeah it's huge it just took a while for
legal Mexican immigrants I think to come
full circle and Donald Trump helped them
get there and usually I think that this
is what's important expect the left to
get very violent to get disruptive yeah
when they say that a vacant vacant
Supreme Court seat Nellie just with the
option of either joining the Nazis or
selecting our death camp yeah they're
currently comparing what's going on with
Nazi death camps you can no longer be
mandated to pay union dues without
choice it's like a schvitz
yeah totally equivalent you have the
right to work freely without the
Teamsters shaking you dad I'm giving you
swirlies you remember that yesterday
remember that yesterday baby that was
your joke in the segment that is
literally our club members please join
cuz you do fan make the jokes is gonna
add justices and I made the joke if
literally a schism the guy literally
says it's hot for its
we get it a joke around anymore it comes
true we can't think of something crazy
about derive jokes don't age well that's
true
haha I think people are though with
Trump do you think they're gonna
remember him as the monster they've
painted him to be for all these years
and probably years afterwards or do you
think they'll people be remembered as
the approval ratings so yeah they that's
a good it's a good question I guess he's
up for debate because I mean there's
plenty of time to screw up yes time
there's so many good things like
verifiably good things happening what
would it take like what would he have
you for people to finally say okay maybe
he's not the worst person in the
I agree and I readily admit I've said
this I was I was wrong I was I really do
think it I was gone
not whether he would win or not but I
actually think he's it doesn't mean that
agree with him personally doesn't mean
he was a tariffs I think he's the right
guy for this job at this time I don't
think Ted Cruz or Rubio or even you know
who I liked Fiorina I don't think they
would have been it's in there it would
have been a lot more of the same for
yeah I think there's a little bit more
leaning to the right I think what you're
seeing with Trump is the evolution of
people who are watching Trump I think
he's growing to disdain the left because
of how horrible they are to him I don't
think that conservative before but I
think he's doubling down now just like
the left is doubling down I made a
Mormon family man because they're coming
after his family non-exact that's
probably makes it much like it's true
those guys
he exposing him for them what they
really are be yeah it's not it coming
out in the kind of showing the real face
yeah probably would have concealed that
but if they're not already exposing
themselves this many in the Democratic
Party do I do think it's gonna get more
violent and this is why we deal with you
know we've been doing with threats all
the time if you convince enough people
that I'm a Nazi for example firebombing
the car / and the tires is totally
acceptable yeah when you look at the
crowd or confront segments it's not
something we wanted to do we've been
doing changed my mind for a long time
we've been getting so we've had to shut
down tables because of violence ended to
shut down shows because of threats of
violence and higher a lot of security
higher a lot of poverty to put it simply
the left is losing because they can't
help themselves from lying yeah that's
what is they cannot help themselves from
like this is like Nazi Germany Trump is
a Trump is separating families the
economy is worse than ever
well we are least and we're less respect
than we ever been as a nation
none of these things are true and and
that's the same reason they can't figure
out why they're losing is because no
one's that good a liar you forget all
your previous lies and you get lost and
you wonder where you are well here they
are exactly R is where the left are
they're at a place where they believe
that the economy is collapsing they
believe that we're being marched into
death camps thus they can justify
violent actions against any political
voice of opposition and they can't
fathom why half the country who have
things better than possibly ever before
certainly in our lifetime don't agree
with them they can't help themselves
from lying they can't remember their
past lies and so here they are this is
why we're divided we have to get gonna
have a Jordan Peterson the Nick DiPaolo
talk more about this with that Jordan
Peterson
[Music]
why hello there say hello not gay Jared
that boy it's no secret that not gay
--jared starts every day with the finest
products for grooming from Dollar Shave
Club but not gay Jerrod as a dirty
little secret tired of the woes from the
old fashioned wipes he knew there had to
be a better way that's precisely where
one wipe Charlies come in from Dollar
Shave Club flushable wipes and
convenient packaging gives you just the
edge you need to be on the body plus the
soothing botanicals leave you feeling
vibrant and refreshed perfect for those
producers who haven't - : try one wipe
Charlies from Dollar Shave Club today
because anything else is a pain in the
ass go to dollarshaveclub.com slash
Crowder for your five dollar starter kit
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash Crowder
for your five dollar starter kit because
they have the balls to sponsor this
program
[Music]
this is a native Honduran dance really
yeah it's cut it's called that I know my
head's on a turtle that's the native
hunter and dance a huge fan of our next
guest I'd like he's selling Stadium
lipstick sorry Oh theaters out across
the country shouldn't say stadiums
that's like Freddie Mercury he's not
quite there yet not enough billboards as
Freddie Mercury but a big fan of him I'd
like to think we've we've helped with
some physics a success we covered it
early on with with Canada and the bill
going on there so you can follow him of
course if you don't know who he is yet
at Jordan B Peterson 12 rules for life
as his book was number one I think it's
still up there
I don't even it could be number one any
given day on Amazon any place you can
get books dr. Jordan Peterson thank you
for being here sir my pleasure thanks
for the invitation it's lovely to meet
someone so sartorial early splendid
yes well listen to appropriate is to
appreciate and the reason we did
Honduras this week is because we've done
it for three years now and we're running
out of ideas so this is as good as we
could come up with a short notice dr.
Peterson I know I know you're touring
right now across the country to sold-out
crowds and of course you've gotten some
protestors some mobs and we released a
video this week - you know a lot a lot
of views a lot of interactions Crowder
confronts and this has been confronting
people who make online death threats or
calls to action or plots of violence and
what was remarkable to me I wanted to
get your take on this as a clinical
psychologist no one with the mob when
they're chanting no one condemned
actions of violence you see this was
Maxine Waters now is coming almost
entirely from the left today but it
seems as though it's accelerated so
rapidly in the last month have you seen
this and explained to people who don't
know the actual phenomena of the mob
mentality that occurs well in a mob
there's distribution of responsibility
right because everyone is faceless and
so well a lot of what keeps people
saying is being held immediately
responsible for their actions and so
right that's why one-on-one interactions
tend to remain peaceful but of course
you can be anonymous in the mob and then
because you can be anonymous if you're
resentful or angry or anything like that
or vengeful then you have the
opportunity to let your worst what would
you say your worst the worst parts of
you manifest themselves without fear of
of being called for your actions before
I interrupt you was that oh what's that
I said before I hit her up was that a
tugboat what was that sound that we just
probably a water okay all right so I
continue were talking about the
accountability but through my headphones
it sounded like a tugboat continue dr.
anthologized well my marble I was people
to hide fundamentally yeah this is also
why you can't really apologize to a mob
you know if you're mobbed online for
example and you apologize there's not
much point in it because you can
apologize to a person and you can offer
to do better and you can say you're Mia
culpas and all that but the mob shifts
and changes on you and and you can't
hold a mob responsible as well which is
another reason why they're so dangerous
that's a really interesting point you
know I I never made the connection with
you know President Donald Trump or
conservative I said listen they're gonna
they'll get or like yourself they're
gonna label you and not see anyway so
you don't need to appeasing crocodiles
as futile as the old term but sometimes
you just connect that really when you
think of the meteor you think of these
people online that it really is just a
mob it's a more diffuse mob it's a mob
across the country but it's still a mob
mentality no less and that's why I've
always said apologizing for the sake of
appeasement is really stupid if you
think you've done something wrong
apologize but these apology tours right
now they never work as rosy in any any
less fired today I don't think so well
the other thing too is is that the the
the part of the mob that you apologize
to isn't necessarily the same mob that
goes after you after you apologize right
you know you have some sense on social
media that that when people come after
you it's a group and it's got defined
borders and so maybe you're interacting
with out and trying to appease it or to
apologize for it but it isn't something
with defined borders and the apology
will just inflame another
mob you can't distinguish it from the
original law it's the same subjectively
but it's not helpful it's not helpful
let me ask you this then separating from
what we've been doing with the Crowder
confront series let's say someone online
finds themselves being mobbed because of
a tweet or something that they posted at
some point and they think they're
actually wrong but they know that people
are going after them because they will
they want to see them destroyed
regardless should they apologize because
they feel they were wrong or should they
just move on down the trail what's the
best way for them to handle it well I
don't know if they should apologize on
Twitter that's for sure because Twitter
doesn't look like a good place for
recent conversations between that might
be something one of the things I've
started to do with Twitter because it's
it's an impulsive medium is that if I
have something to say that needs to be
said in detail then maybe I'll write a
blog about it and then it can be
reasoned and and longer form and I think
that's really important
the short form of Twitter seems to make
people stupid and impulsive
I mean Twitter has its utility but it's
a dangerous medium yeah and then well
and if you're going to apologize you
need to do that very carefully and I
wouldn't do it as you pointed out I
wouldn't do it for appeasement the
purpose of an apology is to set this
situation right between usually between
two individuals and to apologize
properly you have to figure out what you
did wrong you have to figure out why you
did it
then you have to set those things right
so that you won't repeat the error in
the future I mean if you want an apology
from someone say if you've had an
argument with them or if they've
slighted you if you want to maintain the
relationship you want to find out that
they figured out why they did what what
they did right they're doing what they
can to set it right but that they also
won't repeat it in the future
that constitutes an apology but you know
people get afraid when they get mobbed
and then they backpedal because well
sometimes they also think if all those
people objected maybe they were wrong
you know but it doesn't seem to be a
very effective strategy in fact it looks
counterproductive most of the time to me
yeah I think you're right and I think
that ties right back to when you were
saying what's required for an apology
that's why you can't ask a mob to
apologize because they're not capable
well that's also quite droops
it's also why groups don't have rights
right no you could hold an individual
responsible nothing that can't be held
responsible has rights this is why
animals don't have rights
you should treat them properly that's
not the same thing you have a
responsibility to care for animals
properly as much as you can and not to
produce undue suffering but that doesn't
mean that animals have rights and
animals don't have rights and groups
don't have rights because you can't hold
them responsible Jesus it's such an
elementary truth you think that we would
have figured that out after a couple of
hundred years of discussions about right
but it's a crucial issue because
responsibility is well and it's also the
case that response responsibility not
rights that are the bedrock of our
society which is something I've been
talking these crowds about constantly
and everybody's very well I don't know
if they're crowds I've been talking to
the individuals that make up the crowds
that are coming to see me about
responsibility and that seems to be
going extremely well and this violence
thing you'd be talking about like I
would really really caution everyone in
a situation like this to do everything
they can to turn the other cheek because
we're in a situation polarized situation
is very dangerous because one person
slaps the other and then this person
punches this person and then this person
hits this person with a stick and like
it starts to it starts to escalate yeah
and that escalation is really really
dangerous and you want to do everything
you can to forestall that because it can
get out of hand it's a positive feedback
loop and it can get out of hand very
very rapidly yeah it is a positive
feedback loop up yours here's my
question I you know I see a lot of
people out there saying odds we're
polarized as though as though
polarization in and of itself is immoral
it's not if let's say people are
polarized from the Nazis to use the
left--it example not saying anyone here
is a Nazi if our if you find there's a
giant chasm between you and communists I
don't think that being divided on on an
issue is inherently immoral but the
proactive polarization through lies and
through calls to violence in other words
calling your opposition Nazis trying to
paint them as subhuman sort of
caricatures some people out there send
all the left and the right are
responsible I know I don't consider you
right or left I consider you just a
thinker and and some more of a
philosopher in a lot of ways I know I'm
more conservative it's no see with my
audience I contend that it's coming
exclusively from the left on a large
scale today you know yeah well that'd be
that as it may it's still going to be
incumbent on everyone who wants to
maintain peace to keep to keep a level
head
you know and and that that's the crucial
issue
I mean because well what's the
alternative and I would also say we
should look at some situational
variables that are at play here too I've
been thinking about this a lot talking
about it with Rubin some of the other
people in this so-called intellectual
dark web I mean I think part of what's
happening steven is that as the classic
media dies it gets more and more
desperate to attract the remaining
attention that it can attract and so
it's highlighting extreme opinions and
it's doing that in an attempt there
really it's really clickbait and so
that's driving this this apparent
polarization far faster than I think it
actually exists because my sense is that
the vast majority of people out there
are pretty much the same as they were
five years ago and are vastly reasonable
but there's an there's an exaggeration
of the of the of the ideological idiocy
now I share your proclivity to think
that a substantial amount of this is
coming from the radical left you know
and I think that's partly because that's
been subsidized in the universities yeah
that's a that's a huge source of it but
I think it's being exaggerated by the
death throes of the classic media as
these new technologies come up to
supplant them they're getting
increasingly desperate and telling more
and more desperate stories an attempt to
hold on to the fragments of their
audience and so it might be a number a
mirage in some sense this increased
polarization might be a mirage that's a
consequence of the death spiral of the
classic media yeah you know III and I
would hate I hate to disagree with with
dr. Jordan Peterson but I would slightly
because I know you and I I agree with
you have a radical left but here's
something that I ask a lot of people and
I want you and I I know you choose your
words very carefully so what do you
think about it for a second is a genuine
question yeah can you give me anyone
today in 2018 anyone on the National DNC
platform bench who we wouldn't consider
radical left Bernie Sanders Hillary
Clinton Nancy Pelosi debbie Wasserman
Schultz Elizabeth Graham Maxine Waters
Eric Schneiderman
can you name any one of them who would
be as reasonable help people like even a
Rubio on the right I can't find any I
don't think it's a radical left when
it's a platform well it's a good
question you know I mean
I think that the question is to what
degree the moderate left has been
willing or able to separate themselves
from the radical left and this is a big
problem I mean one of the things I've
been trying to puzzle out intellectually
is and I've been challenging the people
that I've speaking with and including
the journalists is like we know the left
can go too far right that's a historical
fact no one disputes that they have any
sense the question is when exactly does
the Left go too far what combination of
policies do they put forth that produces
the the the proclivity towards tyranny
and catastrophe that characterized the
radical left movements in the 20th
century and the answer is nobody's been
able to specify it like I think it's the
Triad in what we're seeing right now the
triad of diversity inclusivity and
equity is a deadly triad especially
equity because that's a cover for
quality of outcome and I think equality
of outcome doctrines are absolutely
catastrophic
I think identity politics itself the
idea that were fundamentally defined by
our group identity I think that's an
absolutely abhorrent policy yeah and and
I think that the left has an absolute
moral obligation to sort that out but I
would also say that it's a technical
problem for the rest of us centrists and
and conservatives as well as left
wingers is like what exactly is it in
the leftist policies that produce the
catastrophic outcome because one thing
you can say about the left I think about
the necessity for the existence of the
left is that hierarchies tend to
dispossessed people and that's a
standard post modernist claim but it's
also true and you and the dispossessed
the working class let's say need a voice
but the problem is is that too much
concern in that direction starts to tilt
and produce very pathological outcomes
and we're certainly seeing that right
now you know and we need to be able to
sort it out intellectually when do they
go too far what what you like the right
goes too far when it makes claims of
racial or ethnic superiority that's
that's kind of the consensus right but
it's not so easy to put your finger on
exactly when the left makes its fatal
error maybe it's a combination of you
know policies does it I don't even know
that I would consider that necessarily
right-wing does the last people to do it
were just racist socialists I mean
look at the tiki torches guys today if
you look at their speeches when they try
to associate this with the right a boho
and listen to their speeches they're
talking about an expanded government
welfare state if only if we got we got
rid of the blacks Browns and juice it's
very very let me ask you this yeah posit
this because you said what is it you
know as far as the left and you talked
about the hierarchy we've talked about
the mob mentality could the through-line
be weakness equality of outcomes that's
a way for compensating for weakness the
mob mentality it's to compensate for
fear of your own weakness when you look
at this demanded hierarchy demanded
power of the state that's one thing that
we've come in consistently these people
who make the threats who call action to
call actions of violence who paint their
opposition as Nazis it seems to be very
weak minded people well it seems to me
that it might be more associated with
with resentment huh
you know because in its resentment
masquerading as compassion but the
problem is it's still hard to delimit as
a policy right you know no you said
something that I thought was interesting
about about the right and the left the
way that I've been conceptualizing the
political landscape at the moment you
know generally we think of right and
left and that and the distribution
between them but I think really the
right way of thinking about what's
happening right now is it's collectivist
versus individualist and then on the
collectivist end you have the left-wing
collectivists and the right-wing
collectivist right and the left-wing
collectivists are playing the victim
narrative and the right-wing
collectivists are playing the ethnic
identity card and that the and so the
real dispute is between the
collectivists and individualists s-- and
you know in in my writings and in my
tours and lectures and so forth i'd be
making a very strong individualist case
because i think the idea that our
societies are functional societies and
let's say our functional Western
societies one of the ideas that we
really got right was the sovereignty of
the individual and the idea that when
you look at the world you should look at
the world you should look at a world of
individuals whether that's historical or
present or future that should be your
conceptual framework primarily focused
on the individual now and the
collectivists and I think the leftists
have the loudest collectivist voice at
the moment the collectivists insists
that no there isn't any individual
there's just a collective and
it's interesting too because of the
left-wing assaults on free speech I've
been thinking of them through it isn't
free speech that the left the radical
leftists are mounting an assault on it's
the idea that there is such a thing as
free speech because the radical leftist
collectivist claim is that you can't
speak as an individual because there is
no individuals you can only serve as a
mouthpiece for the for the power claims
of your group yeah and that's an
unbelievably pernicious ideology so I
think it's the it's the fundamental
proclivity of the collectivists to view
the world through a lens that that that
that that focuses everything on group
identity I think that's the real killer
well you know you're a buzzkill today
because you're not talk about policy
you're talking about deeply rooted
infectious ideology and you're right
damn it Jordan you're right and so when
I show up and Ranger panties and Uncle
Sam costume and get my head almost
knocked off I feel like I have to do
this because they need to be afraid of
somebody
well I've questioned about that too like
so you've been you've been confronting
people who are making claims of violence
and so let me ask you this like first of
all actual flats
okay so what's that being like for you
and do you feel that you're like are you
in flaming things are you satirizing
them like what what role do you think
you're playing in this so a couple of
things I think and that's a good
question
you know as we say in the video sir
every time I move I'm turned out to move
with this ruffling here um we do cheat
we have hours and hours and many many
many dozens of millions of plays and
change my mind videos right where we sit
down and we say anyone can sit down and
have a conversation and it's unedited so
yes they say discussions and this
happened in Austin ruptured there were a
few so you know we've taped it we've
taped a handful of these by the way we
just sit on the footage and let them lie
about it and then release the video
because it's more fun that way so we sat
down we actually had a transgender City
City Council candidate sit down for 40
minutes it was very civil she came back
at another another change my mind and
said hey thank you so much for being so
polite so we had these cats our goal but
when you post our location and you
actively plot to harm me or my crew that
that changes things and the point here
is no longer to convince these people
who want acts of violence to stifle the
conversation
but for people who may not be aware we
have to understand this is one thing
that a lot of people understand probably
about 85% maybe 90% of Americans even
those who are registered Republican or
Democrats they don't necessarily know
what we know they don't live in this
world they don't live in the youtubes in
the blogosphere world they're not aware
of how bad it is out there and so this
kind of content I can tell you you you
can read the comments section thousands
of people going
I was just vaccinated against ever
becoming a Democrat or I cannot believe
it has gotten this bad I really need to
take an active role and join a local
chapter so only this is don't exist on
Twitter yeah I think they're just
Twitter trolls you don't think the oh
these are live people and the truth is
we have we have eyes and ears everywhere
and it's very deeply rooted and I mean
you know we've had some met several
people arrested reported the police for
other acts of violence not including
myself so that's the purpose board have
a conversation when they try to stop a
through violence expose them to the rest
of the world yeah okay and and do you
think that's that seems so on the face
of it very reasonable do you think what
what's your sense do you think that the
fact that you're bringing this to light
is doing more good than the fact that
you're engaged in this is doing harm I
do
yeah I do and again the reason why is
because so many people are not aware and
you get outside of you myself you know
Reuben Shapiro Rogen's of the world and
a lot of people are not aware how bad
the left has become and when they see 20
30 people and none of them will say hold
on a second posting an address and
saying blow up this guy's van with
people in it when no one will say that's
bad the millions of people walking go oh
wow yeah wow this is something I need to
be aware of I need to be careful here
and know what know what the left is up
to so that's the break well it does seem
that we doesn't seem to fall under the
auspices of self-defense at that that in
that situation I mean it's just I'm just
curious about it because and it's not a
criticism it's not on you and it's
genuine Auster you have a large platform
and I'm trying to figure out ways that
that that this can be discussed and and
brought to light say that don't
simultaneously produce the probability
that the violence is going to increase
it's not an easy thing to do I mean a
near point is well it makes more sense
to show what's going on and that that's
the better strap
gee and I guess that's a free speech
strategy in some sense and it's it's one
of our first line of energy is is change
my mind our first strategy is open
discussion and yeah it's it's like in
combat sports we match intensity at a
certain point you've got to get your
dukes up and there are a lot of other
people out there who've been
sucker-punched a lot of other people
who've had tires slashed or haven't been
actively uh I mean they handed you a
knife for the Ben Shapiro event ice pick
at a certain point it doesn't I don't
believe it does anyone I mean with any
favors to sweep it under the rug in the
hopes that these people will be peaceful
especially when you have Maxine Waters
out there encouraging it they're getting
more violent and and it really worries
me and I I do think sunlight for that is
the best disinfectant provided you are
also having discussions and rational
debates which we do and number one of
course it's yeah wildly entertaining
because this is a combination what what
do you think what do you think the
consequences of these change my mind
events that you've been having yeah
those have been fit I mean we I mean how
many millions of comments and people who
actively changed their minds I mean I
can tell you six figures of people who
become pro-life from watching that okay
that's four okay so you you you you
think you have some credible evidence
that those that the rational discussion
end of it is actually producing some
some real exchange of views and some
transformation of outcome yeah yeah so
that would you know I think it's a good
thing I think the number one thing is
you know the show has to be obviously
entertaining it's a late-night show but
the the point is we have eyes and ears
and and our roots really deeply rooted
in the leftist activism I mean d/f FBI
has been calling our guys for
information on an tyfa since Utah
because of how how far we've gotten into
their cryptic messaging and I can tell
people this it's gotten a lot worse the
rumblings are a lot worse well I clean
for your psyche fortunately well none of
my none of my shows have been protested
except one in Portland and there was
about 50 PV surprise surprise I sense
there was about 50 people there and
there was a couple of em Tifa types and
they were dressed in black with masks
you know and that that anonymization of
protesters that's a very dangerous thing
you know when someone shows up and
they're dressed in black and they have a
mask and you can't tell who they are you
know absolutely they're up to no good
what about youtube comment section where
people live anonymously
say whatever they want same thing the
same thing out but in real life or they
just yeah I would say anonymity in those
situations is the hallmark of a
dangerous coward and so for those of you
who are out there hiding behind
anonymity you know that's that's that's
how you're manifesting yourself in
reality dangerous coward and that's a
big part of this too is unmasking the
anonymity if only for if only for the
most violent and the most egregious
offenders all right the book of course
is 12 rules for life highly recommended
if you want to be productive also if you
want to learn about lobsters I always
loved that tidbit when I read this book
at Jordan B Peterson and hey where's the
best place for people to follow your
tour if they're if they're not aware yet
that you might be in their city oh they
can go to Jordan go to my website Jordan
B Peterson comm and look up events yep
and I said I think that you discount
voucher I made for your people for self
authoring is still available too so okay
I'll try and come I think it's Crowder
right yeah that's right that's right and
I highly recommend it self authoring com
twelve rules for life
get the book dr. Peterson thank you so
much we have Nick DiPaolo coming up
please stay safe and enjoy your shows
yep
[Music]
one live read of the week this one is of
course actually for mug club so want to
show you something really quickly we did
this Crowder confronts video this week
in na kijiye can bring this up you can
see YouTube is said that their
algorithms will be based on interactions
comments and likes that's how they want
to feature videos that's what determines
views but there is a disproportionate
number of comments and likes if you look
at our videos the catalog
I mean it's exponentially higher than
comparable videos on the left with far
lower view accountant we're gonna try
and get to the bottom of it but all of
them are D monetized of course a lot of
credit.com slash mug club is the only
thing that allows us to continue to do
these videos whether it's change my mind
whether it's undercover investigations
because these videos are very costly
labor-intensive and we don't make a dime
off of most of these videos on YouTube
so the paid content where the daily show
the full 45-minute show what you watch
your Thurs if you like it you get it
every day a lot of credit calm slash mug
Club ninety nine dollars sixty nine for
students veterans or active military you
can get a week trial it's the only way
to help us fight back here on YouTube
because the squeeze is becoming tighter
and tighter and if you don't want to and
you just enjoy the free content that's
absolutely fine too but you know it
can't sustain itself without your
support we appreciate everyone who does
thank you
[Music]
that's the second native dancer under us
really it's unlicensed tommy-gun it's
the unlicensed official dance of yours
you know I really don't know anything
about Honduras outside of obviously the
the soaring murder all you need to know
because after that the Travel Guide is
useless coffee and tobacco Oh is there
anything else no but you can import
those yeah go there for them they've out
go there pension plans for kidnapping
sure in and undressed our next guests a
huge fan I've talked about this before
and I've said there are two people who I
believe are the funniest comedians ever
Norma coddled who has not been on the
show and there the next man who's been
on the show these two have always been
might been my top fit for the last few
years one of the funniest men on the
face of the earth Nick DiPaolo you can
follow Matt Nick DiPaolo how are you sir
Steven thank you so much quite a
compliment no I'm is my favorite so
really I appreciate it why do you why do
you feel like a broken condom
yeah well appropriate is to appreciate
culture I don't know what kind of
condoms you've been wearing but you
might need to call a doctor
well I get now I get black ones to fool
people say you look I busted through a
condom yeah maybe bleeding on the tip
what job had happened yeah okay that's
no that's that's that sounds like a
wonderful leader you know I hadn't
really looked until I saw myself on the
monitor you're not what you considered a
bikini in Honduras yes yes that's
considered a bikini - actually this is
more so what they swim it's in Saudi
Arabia have you ever seen the aerial
shots of Saudi Arabia the women just
thousands of women drowning in their
full-on burkas in the in the water
an aerial shot I have a summer home over
there so Nick you have by the way
where's the best place for Bill to go to
download your show now online the
podcast the the new podcast is gonna be
debuting we're shooting for July 9 okay
and where they want to go is patreon.com
forward slash then Nick DiPaolo show if
they go there tonight that page should
be up okay so eventually
Joe will sit on my home site Nick dip
calm bread does if this if they want to
subscribe to get in on it early they go
there tonight patreon.com slash D Victor
Paulo
they should give them and give
incentives at patreon to you like if
they give $50 later a private
conversation 100 they get a broken black
condom that's exactly right
free we have a three tier system true
this is what I made it Fredo
is the cheapest one Sonny $30 how much
you have to pay to get you to strangle
the woman who punched you in
Birkenstocks with a piano wire sorry can
I not say that I'm gonna hire somebody
yeah
here's ami here's the leader people
Anthony Koo Mia talked about this last
week and I didn't know I'm so sorry I
didn't I wasn't up to date on this lady
punched you in the face
explained for people who don't know the
story yet because I know it I know it's
it's bad it is kind of funny though so
explain it yes sorry now that the
swelling has gone down I have my sight
back it's hilarious I was at a comedy
club
levity live which is uh it's on the
Jersey side of the Tappan Zee Bridge
it's still New York State its Palisades
it's a beautiful club levity live I love
it for the nicest club in the country
and it was Father's Day night after the
show I come out and people are filing
out an exit door to the left of the
stage instead of out the back so I start
shaking hands and taking pictures this
guy approaches me and says uh can I get
a picture with you I said sure he stands
to my right shaking my hand and he says
boy I like to show a lot but my daughter
wanted to punch you in the face he
didn't even finish the word face and I
got sucker-punched from my left I didn't
know she was Dannemann and I'm he
cracked yeah and like I was you know I
was stunned or in short but even while I
was in shock and stunned my first
instinct was to look at the father and
say did you set me up - yeah I mean it
was so was almost like on cue way at the
end of her was like a sick dogs my
question what did the dad do there I
mean did he did he spank her he didn't
that bit in his reaction again this is
speculation of my partner and I really I
really believe you know the level these
people operate at yes I so I really
think it was the setup where's all they
had
you know just wandering
the Polish Oh Lise you usually know
what's coming so you should yes yes
particular which is why people should go
to Nick dip calm and check out the rest
of your tour dates because our fans love
it no punches - laughs yeah so he yeah I
mean I look right at him and he I don't
remember him restraining her or going
what are you doing yeah so his reaction
was trying to wear too but they did but
then you know then the whole thing
pulled out to the lobby and he said well
no my dog has emotional problems and I
shouldn't have breath brotherbrother
[ __ ] no another week your weaponize your
daughter base yeah exact Circe hasn't
that female privilege where she can
punch a man consequence-free
could you imagine the headlines if Amy
Schumer got slugged outside of an event
I said that because every time I do it
into a lot of people well both sides are
getting pretty I said don't like with
the cake no show fun example of a
straight white male comedy club audience
member going after eight a black comic a
gay comic a female comic but because of
their act look right up she hit me I
said why'd you do that she says you're
mean and then she thought appalling okay
broken clock is Right once it right but
she would you know up in the lobby again
you know when the I would try to talk to
me I said no don't get you then she
starts bawling and she starts bawling
they got you to think you were evil yeah
thank God she call you a Nazi like me
you know they would have lined you to
put it up for the firing squad I really
do believe Nichols I was just talking
with dr. Pearson about this and I
respectfully disagree we were saying you
know the radical left a radical right in
Mwanza and I asked him a question I
don't think we really got an answer on
it
and I understand because he wanted to
speak kind of in a more general sense of
where we are as a country that's the
conversation too but I said home we
talked about the radical left is there
anyone on the National DNC platform who
isn't read it well Hillary Clinton
debbie Wasserman Schultz Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren Maxine Waters all of
them are this Pelosi are this bad and if
if they're not flirting with these kinds
of people they're outright demanding
this kind of a can we see it all the
time it's not both sides and I'm really
sorry you had to deal with that that's
horrible well yeah and I don't even
throw her in the far left Kennedy's a
twenty-year-old college dude
so this is about par for the coolest
food for the left right guy yeah she's
not a fringe he's not fringe no she
[ __ ] volunteering summers at the
Registrar's Office
yeah no exactly so so you know and she
you know I don't wanna hear about all
mental illness or whatever she she can
take care of herself at college so she
can't be that you know so yeah my I was
it was growing I could feel like growing
I now know what a boxer goes through I
could hardly see laughter like a flat
for like a minute yeah and and then her
then they tried to you know I told to
snap hold them and get the cop so I had
to tell people what to do and so the
cops showed up she said she thought you
said get the cops that's why she got ya
then then you were part of the hash tag
me to know that she would have ran out
of there I said well who listen she was
crying after she punched you
well after I told her father yeah you
better get a lawyer
dude you're in Beach he went over to her
that hey I'm not a what did you sky I
know the only thing I hate more than
lawyers a feminist
it reminds me of the scene in The Life
Aquatic where Jeff Goldblum walks over
and disciplines the other guy's dog with
a rolled-up paper
I mean you know I will and this is I
really do hope that this gets resolved
and and justice is served but I will say
this I remember having this conversation
with with Joe and with yourself I
remember at one point saying like ah I
don't think he's ever gonna come to the
clubs because you and I both agreed like
we won't do colleges anymore I said I
think you'll be surprised I think that
business owners have to be careful if
only for situations like now you've just
described well here it is now they've
come for the clubs yeah yeah you know
and I security what wasn't around
because I wasn't planning on shaking
hands you know clubs have now they
actually have a backdrop you stand in
front of and that's up in the lobby
right I just have to come out of the
green room I went in after the show and
then I went in the green room for a few
minutes came back out and they just
happen to be filing oh yeah well I
so I started shaking hands sort of an
impromptu great meet and greet and
as a question I think is a thought that
nowhere else it but but the Internet in
2018 is this really happened because
people are formulating these negative
thoughts about comedians in the comedy
clubs used to be a day where you had to
go and see them in the comedy club and
we were act for a bit yeah and then if
and if you didn't like them there then
you're the you're the butthole yes but
then I can go home and watch the clips
on Twitter and formulate your opinions
that you're not it usually takes people
a long weekend to realize they don't
like Nick yeah my wife is twenty-four
years she's still not sure it's a long
way but I said and I I think I was the
first comment to start saying this I
started saying this five years ago now I
see everybody saying this but when when
when people walk out of my show I maybe
even more than five years ago I will
yell to them did you do your research
before you came to the club right you
just see what the headliner was you know
you don't know what music venue
expecting to see Zeppelin and you know
be surprised it's men without hats you
go to see Alice Cooper and I thought
this was gonna be playing piano at
Carnegie Hall they think they think
comedy is a homogeneous thing we all
have the same sense of humor and that's
why I think and I'm not super famous so
yeah there are people who wander into my
show who might not knowing but not too
many anymore I've been doing this a long
time wait this went down putting two and
two together
I don't doubt that they they sat at
their house and said I hate this guy's a
racist let's go to a show and again
speculation I can't even get a galbi I
can't get a call back from the assistant
district I'm yeah I can imagine what
what if I heard Steve I'm a be in jail
for 11 days now well don't don't do it
as much as I'd like to and if you do
televise it and you know we'll be sure
to get exclusive rights turn the channel
here's what I will say oh we do have to
get going
I when we get off air here in a little
bit let me let me talk with you we have
someone who might be able to help out
the Beast and see what's going on if we
can get some info on this person because
we've been doing this segment here
Crowder confronts recently where we can
find almost we can send a missile up
your up your posterior
from anywhere in the country right now
know where you are who you're with at
any given
and I bet you we could probably find out
who this person is and what the plans
were I'd like to help you if we can it
is I know
no no but we'll talk more about it off
air off air I would like to help you
with this and now I would never mention
because I get you know I'm look you can
wait we can't hit back we got it true
gender equality I could have popped her
in the face and everybody would have
said she had they're coming and we went
on our merry way I don't think that's
what they would have said that is true
gender equality yes and so I didn't do
that so I'm gonna take it to the courts
I don't give it I don't care how long it
takes I'm gonna make an example of this
person no I I agree and we worked a lot
with her we were just talking with
Jordan Peterson about this what's the
police with you know antiphon Utah and
some information some and sometimes
these people actually reveal a little
more information than you you might even
know so I'd like to be able to help you
with that but yeah what you need to do
is get in a DeLorean just go through
some HRT go back to her wrestling meet
and win it win the state title because
that's okay now so it's Nick dip calm
you can follow him at Nick DiPaolo PA o
L and the patreon is what Nick for
people to support the show patreon.com
fluid / the Nick DiPaolo show that'll be
up tonight and that's where people who
go to subscribe once this podcast kicks
off and it's gonna be Christmas I'll be
streaming live audio and video all over
the place and we're doing it right I
built I mean I'm in the samples hall
screen is Boop right now oh but if it
sounds like you're an immense truck stop
and connected he we gotta go Nick thank
you so much we'll be right back
[Music]
these days on the right things can seem
pretty rough if you just watch me the
stream news college campuses are full
bernie bros no love for us on youtube
there's one thing you gotta understand
the left has no long-term plan
so we keep winning so much these days
yes
we drove Maxine Waters crazy
you wanna hang with people who respect
the Constitution and don't act rude you
wanna be aware people don't just blame
white dudes
we got judges now who aren't super
pumped about killing babies Chuck Shore
is pissed and I'm pretty sure Nancy
Pelosi has rabies
our economy is doing great
and we don't have to bake your cake
we keep winning so much these days
it drove Maxine Waters crazy you wanna
hang with people who respect the
Constitution and don't act rude you
wanna be where people don't just plain
white dudes
[Music]
[Music]
what else make it out okay
you made it I made it yeah yeah thanks
for asking so was I being waterboarded
there's one person here who's been
waterboarded yeah whatever
and it's the BA very little thanks so
much the doctrine Peterson Nick DiPaolo
next week we don't have any shows but we
do have a giant fourth of July theme
change my mind on Monday Monday huge
that's a lie third Monday yeah still
America superior to all the countries
change my mind and uh sit gerald's
because he had a point I did have a
point I asked you a question earlier why
is it that you know there's nothing that
would seem to change their mind on on
Donald Trump why is that always the case
with power anytime somebody comes along
and actually does something good and it
threatens your power base you just
completely ignore all the good yeah and
just go after protecting your power
that's exactly what the Democrats are
doing right now he could come along and
cure cancer and we've said this before
it literally and they would find a
problem with it they would say that it's
bad for the medical field or something
see that's what's good about Bernie
Sanders there's nothing good about
Bernie's no I'm not doing the exact same
thing if Bernie Sanders could bring
something good to the table like if he
had an economic plan that was good then
I would say that doesn't he has
socialism it's not gun don't get me
wrong no I think I think you're right
that's why I said I I mean we've had
you've admitted that you were wrong on a
lot of it I was definitely wrong in a
lot of it I think some I really you know
the arrogance of some of the
pseudo-intellectual conservative right
sometimes when I listen you've also got
a beat there are things that he does I
disagree with but we've also got to
acknowledge some of the things that he
does that have been good
and I'm surprised let it more credit
than more credibility yeah has to listen
if they would just acknowledge a few
good things like like they can't seem to
have another Obama like I'm like okay
actually this is this is a good thing
yeah and then you have it's a lot much
easier to conversate well it couldn't
conversate is rodman so last week's of
people were a little ups a that i did
the drowning dances Moses to take
advantage and base people didn't think
it was pretty you know the this this
last segment is usually somewhat
inspirational so let me let me shorten
this for you real really quickly you
want some self-help tips here's a stuff
for you to return
telling you a lot of it'll say well hold
on sometimes your advice contradicts
your previous advice like you talked
about working our but then you talk
about being disciplined with rest not
all life tips okay and we get we get our
we get a lot of these requests coming by
email a lot of people you know person
who sent his Navy Cross people who have
unbelievably touching moving stories
these are the people I try to respond to
not people who are just looking for
get-rich-quick schemes which by the way
burn we're not rich we have a
semi-successful
online show late night show okay no one
here is has their own Learjet now like
the Rye alien code guy who led that's
what you start a cult so not all life
tips and this is one thing because ever
wants to say they're not for all people
at all times so if you're on a bike Jael
knows this you're about to climb a
mountain it's gonna be very different
advice or if you're speeding downhill
absolutely right yes it's an entirely
different tact can't believe you just
used a cycling term but is that not true
it's absolutely true so for so first one
is simple right for most people you've
got to start pedaling you just sitting
most people just sitting on a bike
that's it first tip for life moved it
move that's it just start pedaling
that's that's going to be one of the
harder parts is move if things aren't
improving just stop moving there you go
I'll give you a little bit of an al
sharpton there I didn't even tend to you
don't need to worry about wasted motion
yet you don't or wasted energy because
you're just a lysergic blob okay you're
not using any energy so don't worry
about conserving it the first step is
move getting a bike started is a lot
harder than keeping it in motion most
people never creative goal and chart a
path
this one's cuz there's a little bit of
an email that kind of ticked me off this
is someone who thought that I figured
out but like I just need this little
note let me tell you you don't have any
of it figured out okay some people don't
I didn't at one point they didn't but
this is a little bit of tough love this
didn't gain might hit you on the teeth a
lot of people never actually start down
the path if they do chart a path so do
something that's the first step now once
you're moving once you've actually been
putting in the reps you need to
challenge yourself every now and then
you need to something as hard as you
possibly can so you start moving here's
tip to as hard as you can
find your breaking point sprint up that
hill as fast as hard as you can feel
your legs burn feel yourself / feel
yourself really close as though you're
just about to die only to see that crest
if you never redline the engine if you
ever push yourself as hard as you can it
doesn't matter whether it
whether it's in in business whether it's
in sports whether it's an actual cycling
whether it's in being the best husband
you can be whether it's being the best
boss you can be whether it's using your
influence as Bessie you never get to see
that sunset over the hill so every now
and then sprint as hard as you can start
by moving if you're doing nothing that's
the bulk of yeah and push yourself
challenge yourself find out your limits
then between all that is a the most
important we've talked about this with
Brian Shaw we have top athletes and in
between so you hear me talk about the in
between the hills right in between the
beautiful scenic views you just got you
got to keep moving
you got to keep pedaling a lot of times
people think it's the sprints and some
people are better at downhill and it's
the people who are consistent at the at
the end of this finish line
consistency is keep it and be deliberate
about resting okay at this point because
you've already started moving now do I
have to people look lost even said be
delivered about rest
you haven't even pedaled son be
disciplined about resting be disciplined
about Pat be disciplined about working
when no one's watching when it's not
sexy that's the bulk of everything in
life the unsexy in-betweens make up I'd
say 80% of life success whether it's
your marriage whether it's your business
whether it's your job whether it's it's
it's your athletic and that your your
body your health and no one wants to
hear it 80% of success comes from unsexy
in-betweens
when no one is what it's not some
inspiring journey with a beautiful Monet
backdrop so you need to learn to love or
at the very least love why you're doing
the in-betweens and if you do all this
this is one thing too when we had kind
of we did the SMU show was so big and I
spoke with Mackie Gerald's like I'm not
really success I'm not really
comfortable with a certain level of
success why because no one prepares you
for it so if you're lucky enough and
there's something no one prepares you
for success you know why because people
who are successful don't make up the
market share of BS self-help books
there's not a huge that's not there's
not a huge selling that's what had to
stop going to a church that one time we
attended because every single time the
pastor spoke was talking about the broke
and the damage and how the Lord will
heal you and the Lord will heal you okay
absolutely well I believe this is a
Christian but I've never heard a message
about people who'd had their crap
together and how they could help heal
others so most people want to feel sorry
for themselves it's safe most people
like the crutch of oh well someday I'll
get there here's a secret most people
don't want to get there they think they
do what they don't they fear true
success they're repelled by it I've seen
time and time again so this is the part
that no one prepares you for step one
move alright step two redline and every
now and then to know how far you can
take yourself step three the in betweens
then success let's say you've crested
you've seen that sunset you're going
downhill you've got a tailwind you don't
have to pedal as hard you know this
you're moving a lot faster oh yeah
that's where a lot of the crash has
happened almost all of the crashes it's
because it's one of the most straining
parts of life of the journey to use a
term but it's in a way that's the
opposite of that it's the least
physically straining and it's one of the
most mentally taxing now it requires
something that a lot of people haven't
learned because you can't learn this
until you get there what's most
important once you're successful once
you've gotten moving well think about
anything you've accomplished right
whether you're good in hockey whether
you're a star student athlete whether
you're a leader at your church control
you reach that point where okay I've
learned how to play guitar okay I've
learned how to skate okay I've learned
how to be what it now what comes into to
play more is control control of your
bike control of yourself
everything's speeding by this is why you
feel unstoppable once you get success
everyone wants to be your friend right
money women or men whatever you want it
could be success in your marriage could
be success at school
anything could be success take your pick
but the second you hit that stride is
when temptation comes not only from
external sources but internally you
forget to control the bike and you crash
how many cautionary tales have we seen
just just an hour experience since
having done this shelf as this show
started people who just fade it away or
burned out even in this exact movement
I'm sure you can think of a few it's why
after SMU and this is kind of crazy
ascent to what moderate level of success
we've had at a very visceral realign
crisis because I I didn't I didn't know
I didn't want to be like that and what
I've seen so many people who've hit this
level of success and then it just goes
away I didn't want to squander our
influence or our responsibility so here
you want to be successful simple move do
something anything start moving then
push your limits
okay the bulk of it is in betweens when
no one's looking how are you acting how
are you behaving when no one is watching
and then finally if you're lucky enough
to have charted a path and reach success
not many do even fewer hold on to it
control be in control of yours be master
of your own domain and guess what
can't if he didn't follow steps one
through three that's why people who win
the lottery kill themselves in record
numbers or transgenders but right now
were using a different analogy people
who become overnight sensations they
never hold on to success follow those
rules and it's a way of life map out a
plan follow the rules I guarantee you
you may not be a may not be a world
beater but you'll be more satisfied with
your life than you are now and I think
you know who I'm talking to thank you
for sending the email I hope that helps
it may not be what you want to hear but
it's what you need here
[Music]